[موسيقى]
اموال الارجنتين صارت تصل الى نونس لعب
دورتموند المريض يعود للملاعب بكم يهربوا
من مباراه بسبب المعجبين هذه الاخبار هو
غيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
بعد مرور اربع سنوات بالضبط منذ وفاه
اللاعب ايميليانو سالا قام نادي كارديف
سيتي بدفع القسط الاول لنادي نوت الفرنسيه
والمقدر بنحو سبعه ملايين يورو وكان
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
بحرمانه من ابرام اي صفقه
لثلاثه فترات انتقال بسبب التاخر في دفع
مستحقات الفريق الفرنسيه
في المانيا الشركه الافغاني سيباستيانهار
في اول مباراه له على الاطلاق مع فريق
دورتموند الذي انتقل اليه سيف الماضي قبل
ان يصاب بمرض السرطان خلال فتره الاعداد
وشركه على الكبديل في مباراه الوديه امام
فريق برشلونه كما حي الجماهير التي قدمت
لتشجيعه بعد تعافه من المرض الخبيث
وبعد انتقال البنيه روميو للاعبين مع فريق
للشباب قرر ديفيد بكم حضوره اول مباراه من
المدرجات لكن النهايه لم تكن عاديه حيث
ترى بيك من الهروب من المشجعين والمعجبين
خلفان خلف الملعب والتخفي وسط الاشجار قبل
نهايه المباراه الخطه كانت غريبه لكنها
ناجحه وتمكن نجم منتخب انجلترا السابق من
العربي من 500
بعد المباراه لالتقاط الصور او الحصول على
توقيع
في خبر الاخير على نموراتها لاعب اتلتيكو
مدريد الاسبانيه عن تواجدي زوجته في
العنايه المركزه بعد معاناتها من مضاعفات
الولاده مراتها كتب على انستغرام بان
طفلته بخير والام تمر بفتره صعبه لكنها
قويه واس ستتزوجها مع فريق يضم افضل
الاطباء في المستشفى الجامعي لنظاره وتعدى
المولود الجديد هي الرابعه في عائله الفار
موراتا الصغيره
[موسيقى]